a ver esto es un esfuerzo de ortega por
quedarse en el poder de por vida
ya
el perdió cualquier interés por mantener
una fachada democrática aquí lo que se
ha consolidado es una dictadura más
latinoamericana al cual existe en cuba o
en venezuela y para ortega la opinión de
la comunidad internacional y de aquellos
que en nicaragua se oponen a su régimen
no vale no cuenta está actuando como lo
hizo en su momento somos a recordemos
que ortega es también responsable por
masivas y gravísimas violaciones a los
derechos fundamentales ejecuciones
torturas desapariciones de personas
en esas circunstancias este proceso
tiene cero credibilidad y lo que cabe
hacer es a partir de esta fecha entender
que ortega gobierna con un régimen de
facto y no debe recibir el más mínimo
reconocimiento internacional